Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Today’s video is like the human heart
and barbershop quartet harmonies: it comes
to you in four parts. Part 1: The Holidays.
Hank, here in the United States
there are several holidays coming up.
And this year both Christmas Eve and New Year’s Eve
fall on Tuesdays, and I will be taking
both those days off.
Part 2: related. I've been thinking
about burnout a lot lately.
I’m not really burnt out at the moment,
but I am starting to think differently about
the role work plays in my life.
Ever since I was about 22, I've worked
many nights and most weekends.
I don’t recommend working that way and I
don’t need to, but I've continued to do it anyway.
My central goal for the next decade is to do
fewer things that the world constructs as “work”
and more things that are valuable but not usually
imagined as “work,” like spending time with family
and doing the dishes and sleeping and reading and
volunteering my time and talents to causes I care about.
I’m just saying that out loud in the hopes
that it will make me accountable.
Part 3: The Project for Awesome.
So Hank, back in 2007 when we first came up with
the idea for the Foundation to Decrease Worldsuck,
it was mostly a joke, like we "decreased worldsuck"
by paying for people to go to their first concerts.
Which is a value added to the universe, I
think, but maybe not the most efficient one.
But then the Project for Awesome started to
grow, and the Foundation to Decrease Worldsuck
became a real charity that can accept tax
deductible donations despite its very silly name.
And last year, the Project for Awesome raised
its ten millionth dollar for charity.
The P4A is my favorite time of the year, and
I can't wait for the strange mix of exhaustion
and exhilaration it brings.
The 13th annual—how is that possible—
Project for Awesome will happen this year
between noon Eastern Time on Friday December 6th
and noon Eastern on Sunday December 8th,
but the Indiegogo will launch this year
on December 3rd.
There will be many amazing perks available—more on
those next week—and because the Project for Awesome
is a volunteer-run organization, except for
credit card fees and the cost of making
and shipping physical perks,
all donations go to charity.
As in past years, during the first half
of the Project for Awesome,
we’ll be raising money for pre-selected charities,
Save the Children and Partners in Health,
both of which our community has worked with for over
a decade, and both of which have excellent reputations
for reaching and assisting the most
vulnerable people in the world.
I should mention that this year’s P4A fundraising
will be entirely separate from the project
we announced a couple of months ago
with Partners in Health Sierra Leone.
Over 3,000 of you have joined us in donating to support
the strengthening of Sierra Leone’s healthcare system,
and we are so grateful and excited to watch
that progress over the next several years.
But during this year’s P4A, as in past years,
we’re raising so-called “unrestricted funds,”
which allows PIH and Save the Children to
spend the money wherever it’s most needed.
Partners in Health, for instance, might need
money to support a clinic in the Navajo nation
or to buy medical supplies in Haiti. They know better
than we do where the funding gaps are,
and unrestricted funds are really important to charities,
so we’re keeping the Sierra Leone project separate.
If you have any questions about this or about
anything, please leave them in the comments!
It occurs to me that someday YouTube will probably
move the comments section to like a sidebar,
and then it will look to people like
I’m just pointing at my pants.
And then it occurs to me that someday, YouTube will
not exist at all. But back to the Project for Awesome!
Right, okay, so during the second half of
the Project for Awesome, as in past years
we will be raising money for charities
chosen by you.
YOU make a great video in support of a charity
you think deserves a grant
and then upload it on Friday December 6th,
and if people vote for it at projectforawesome.com,
that charity might receive part of the funds
raised during the second half
of the Project for Awesome.
So we’re counting on you to make great videos and pick
worthy charities. Alright, let’s talk about money!
Hank and I will be matching the first $150,000
raised in this year’s Project for Awesome.
And I know lots of you have donated to lots
of causes, so really no pressure,
but if you would like to join that matching fund,
you can email us at ftdws@complexly.com.
That email address is also in the dooblydoo
and in the comments below.
If you are able to join the matching fund,
you will be thanked profusely
and it really does help drive donations.
Okay, Part 4!
For making it to the end of an update video,
you win a picture of my brother and me as reindeer—
one of the amazing months of
the 2020 Project for Awesome calendar.
Rudolph, I’ll see you on Friday.